this is seems like one of those
singularly American what began as a
feel-good story obviously people heard
you talk they know you're not from here
how did you come across this story
someone brought it into a producible to
into the production company I was
working out the company's called Roth
they made her theatrical talk a few
years back called the imposter and
they've got a film out at the moment
called American animals and I guess a
lot of my career's been spent in
development in ideas and you get quite
cynical and quite jaded quite quickly
you feel you've seen every idea there is
to be made and when this one came in
there instantly I was I just this is the
single greatest story I've ever I've
ever come across and and and it works on
a kind of human level there's a
compelling human story it's hard but it
also has these much bigger themes of
freewill destiny family and I instantly
always I have I have to make this film
five years later it's we're here what
took five years four years of that was a
combination of raising funding which
took longer than you might think
especially in the UK to get that side of
it but also mainly winning the trust of
the brothers I mean when you see the
film you understand why they might find
it hard to to trust people and it just
took a long time to build that trust I
think got to fold one because of
obviously what had happened to them but
also when they were famous in the 80s a
lot of people promise them stuff a lot
of media people promise themself so they
were very that never materialized so
very cynical about us you ended up
directing but you were originally the
producer what what happened here
director or well I was originally the
development producer and at the start
all kinds of big you know all the
biggest names in documentary were being
sort of touted about as direct and I
just sort of quietly kept on
ingratiating myself with the story and
the contributors till it got to the
point that they couldn't really get rid
of me
beause I was very lucky the production
company and and CNN films in particular
took took a chance on me was it fully
fledged when it came to you all the
knowledge about the Louie loos why
center about Doctor Neubauer
or did this open up as you began working
on it no absolutely not I mean we had we
had about 50 or 60% of the backstory I
think that we can have new but it exists
in this kind of pre-internet era where
the we're fortunate that most of the
people are still alive or a lot of them
are to talk about it but it wasn't
something you could
research on the Internet and then we
literally my producer sat in Jewish
archives in New York for you know months
on end and we went and met people and
you know like Natasha knew Bowser sister
I don't think she's ever smoking on
camera before so there was a loss of
old-fashioned journalism when it went
into it and as far as as digging into
the story itself did the brothers have a
clue about how big this story was they
knew their own piece of it but did you
bring a bigger picture to them yeah I
mean they've dug away at it for a bit
and then I thought they'd been knocked
back so many times and had so many you
know approached so many lawyers about
the case he told them they couldn't take
it on because of statute of limitations
or because of conflict of interest
involvement with some of the players in
the Jewish world of Family and Children
Services or the Louise wise agency that
they'd sort of given up and I think I
mean I think the real revelation for
them was that it was about parenting I
mean we're pretty sure as sure as you
can be that that was a particular focus
of the study I think they're at the
point now when nothing nothing will
surprise them if you've lived the life
they have you know and essentially
they've lived there kind of Truman Show
almost like existence at the start their
lives I don't think anything really
shocks them anymore but they make some
angry definitely when it came to
structure for a documentarian you have
to have enough material to tell the
whole story sometimes there are
narrative gaps did you run into any of
those and did you think oh my god this
is gonna derail what we're doing this is
really unusual for a documentary saying
that a lot of documentaries i watch
feature talks i think there isn't quite
enough material to sustain you know
ninety minutes and this was we had a
surplus of material for this and
actually there were there was pressure
put on us to make it into a miniseries
or something like that but I always you
know I'd always aspired to make it as a
theatrical dock there are definitely
visual gaps and that's why we ended up
using the reconstruction at the start of
the film initially we didn't want to at
all but what I realized as we were
making it is that those early scenes are
really important in terms of aligning
the audience with with the boys you know
you want to be discovering things as
they discovered it and that inciting
incident he's a sort of screenwriting
term of the Bobby going to college for
the first time and big mistake
everything else stems from that all our
knowledge about the study you know I
think if he hadn't gone to that College
we
might still be sitting here knowing
absolutely about nothing about the study
and the boys could be lived living
separate lives Eddie might even still be
alive for all I know you know so it was
really important to dramatize those
those opening parts I thought that your
decision to shoot the surviving triplets
separately was a creative decision of
yours was it just that they wouldn't sit
on camera together it no it was a
creative decision but they weren't they
weren't speaking I mean the relationship
was very very fractured and actually the
yeah the first time we'd gotten together
was that where you see them sit down I
mean that's all genuine that that kind
of sort of awkwardness and the weird
thing about my interviews they turned up
wearing the same shoes exactly the same
shoes and they hadn't spoken for like
eight months previously so I thought
they were like sort of messing with me
but they genuinely did and said that
there are these weird twin triplet
things that happen when you're filming
that you couldn't predict does go dark
is almost that Hitchcockian shocker
because you're watching it and you think
Louise wise Jewish adoption center Nazis
and and you gasp if you can't help that
but when people you screened it for
people when you've shown it to people is
that for them the turning point and did
you mean that to be the turning point
for this doc I think we wanted that to
be the turning point of Revelation in
terms of the sort of Nazi connection I
mean I'm not Jewish my wife's Jewish she
finds it really really uncomfortable
that watching this film she finds it
really difficult because this is sort of
for her it's like Jewish people don't do
this kind of thing to other Jewish
people especially because the legacy of
the Holocaust and Mengele and so I
wanted it to be in there but I didn't
want to labor it too heavily I wanted it
to feel like a universal story but it's
absolutely a central irony of this story
that David's family fled Austria because
of the Holocaust and Peter knew Bowers
family fled Austria because the
Holocaust and they ended up on either
side of this experiment it was so
interesting to hear the very cheerful
tone of the researcher the woman who
worked with dr. Neubauer
the sense that well this is what we did
this was science you know how can you
turn down science and almost being
abstract about it I mean Natasha is one
of the most extraordinary people that
I've ever interfered in my life I mean
actually the two older women in this
film for me at the heart of it you know
Natasha is the research we work with
noubar and then David Arendt
who's kind of like for me the moral
center of the film and they both give
they both had very different things to
say
I think Natasha in her defense it was a
different time and there were a lot of
experiments done in the 50s and 60s when
psychology was kind of established
itself as a kind of science it was
Lawrence calls it the Wild West of
psychology and things like the Milgram
obedience experiments and later the
Stanford Prison Experiment you would
never be able to get those past this
psychology ethics about physical pain
among other things exactly you would net
you never and yeah you would never be
able to do them but I do think that the
time and also that the two people who
speak in the film their peripheral
relative very peripheral to the study
whereas I we know of psychiatrists who
are in New York practicing today who are
heavily involved in setting it up and
they're quoted in you know they're
mentioned in all the meetings in in the
notes that we've got and we contacted
them they said well I don't know what
you're talking about
not me how did this film change you that
is a really good question it changed me
it changed me in the sense that well I
had a son while I was making this film
and suddenly all this debate about
nature-nurture became very personal you
know and when he was born he was born
with a personality and I I I don't think
I'd ever realized quite just how
strongly that genetic imprint is there
from the start so that was that was
pretty shocking but it's made me think a
lot about ethics and filmmaking actually
because the parallel there are parallels
with scientific experimentation you have
a huge amount of power as a filmmaker
and how you willed that power is is
really important and it's easy to lose
track of that in pursuit of a great
story just as I would argue that these
people did in pursuit of a great
experiment because but what we don't see
is how you got people to agree to be on
camera
what concessions you had to me what what
trade-offs you had to make so that's
really what you're talking about when
you read a study a scientific study
they're supposed to tell you how they
arrived at those conclusions but we're
filmmaking the same thing you don't see
how the film comes together you just see
the film I think it's what yeah I think
it's more so that people tell you stuff
that you could use in the film and you
know sometimes you do that maybe you
know will hurt them or upset them I just
you have to be constantly aware of the
position of power you're in and
and be ethical in your use of the
information people will tell you all
kinds of things when you put a camera on
them particularly if people haven't been
through like therapy or anything like
that in their lives they use you as a
therapist and you're suddenly in a
position when you can art where you can
awesome anything and pretty much they'll
answer if you have that that kind of
connection with them so you just have to
be really mindful I think that you don't
abuse that in pursuit of your goal which
is to make a really powerful moving film
Tim Wartell thank you so much for
delivering this film thank you for being
here today